yeah I don't buy it when people say oh
well it's just like the printing press
isn't it I mean aside from the fact the
printing press um triggered Wars of
religion that lasted a century you know
which is maybe isn't a great parallel if
you're trying to Excuse excuse the harms
of the internet um I mean I think it
should be intuitive if particularly when
it comes to the effects on children
because any adult who uses screens
regularly will should surely notice the
effect that it has on them you know if
you've spent hours looking at a screen
you're not just going to have a sore
neck you know you do nor have a kind of
psychological malays which I think um
most people do notice in themselves we
know that smartphones are very addictive
we know that you know using porn using
social media all of these things has has
affects our relationships our social
lives I think that it ought to be
obvious that all of those effects which
adults clearly identify um would be even
more um acute in children because they
are because because they're still
developing